Carroll is with us in San Francisco hey
Carol how are you thank you can you
speak directly into your phone you're a
little fussing Carol Carol can you speak
directly into your phone you're a little
fuzzy okay that is that better yes ma'am
thank you oh okay we have three grown
sons the oldest is financially set our
youngest is financially underwater but
he came to us
and rather than bailing him out we
bought him Financial Peace University
okay
main concern is our middle son who has
our three grandchildren he's 40 his
finances come from donations from you
know supports on people friends and
relatives and that type of thing this
last summer we gave them $14,000 and
that amount because I could get that
without having to pay any taxes on it as
they were going to a training session
across country then in I'm sorry he
lives off of donations a lot of
financial support from friends and
relatives and that type of thing yeah
for what reason why does he not have an
income he does have an income through
that from donations from his relatives
from friends and relatives around the
country yeah why is he in ministry or
something yes yes okay yeah okay so he
has a support group for supporting the
ministry that he is in correct I got any
is three kids all right I got you
he has three children okay so last time
we gave them $14,000 in cross country
and to you know do some financial things
that they needed well then in October
they came to us saying that they needed
some they were going to have to rent
another house and they needed money to
get out of the stress that they were in
and to buy a new refrigerator stove in
place after your phone is breaking up
again you're going to speak directly
into it darling
okay what part didn't you hear that he
heard it all but it's just getting hard
to hear so I keep please keep speaking
straight into it come to find out I was
I found out that they bought season
passes to Disneyland and that my
daughter-in-law went to Cancun an
all-inclusive trip but yet in October
then they came to us saying they needed
these finances and stuff I'm not up for
that we also put them through Financial
Peace University they told us that the
hall financed help available to them
through their company no I'm sorry their
company well--there's ministry oh we're
going okay ministry so you know they're
going to be getting quite a lump sum
when we die until then do we keep
finance no labeling them to live without
their rings no no they're using the
ministry as an excuse to be
irresponsible that's my feeling
that's what you just described right
when I can't pay my rent and I have to
go to my mother-in-law for rent after I
went to a trip to Cancun that's kind of
a problem that is a problem yeah no I
think do you live in the same area that
they're in they live in Southern
California we live in Northern
California okay will you be with them in
person anytime soon no okay all right
well I think maybe that you and your
husband get on the phone with the two of
them and and here's what it sounds like
if I'm you guys okay you can do whatever
you want but you're asking me so this is
what I would do if this was my kid I
would just say look we've given you
money for years we love you we love our
grandkids we feel like we are giving a
drunk a drink we feel like we're in a
blurs because you continue to misbehave
with money and
come to us as your backstop every time
we don't mind helping you but we don't
feel like we're helping you anymore and
we feel like we're harming you because
we're financing your irresponsibility
thereby encouraging it and we don't want
to do that anymore because we love you
too much we want what God wants for you
and that is a life of abundance and
you're not living a life of abundance
you're living a life of financial stress
because you're disorganized and you have
your priorities out of whack now it can
be mad at us we don't want you to be mad
at us we love you we love the grandkids
and we want to help you but we're not
going to just willy-nilly give you money
anymore you're going to go through
Financial Peace University we're going
to pay for it or we're not going to give
you any more money and we need to let
you know that and that is an act of love
on our part not an act of vengeance not
an act of anger we love you and we don't
want to cause you to continue to be
irresponsible and giving you money and
financing your irresponsibility is
causing that and we've come to realize
we brought you harm and we don't want to
harm you we love you too much okay is
enough so they're wanting more money for
this move and everything I said well
what happened on the fourteen thousand
dollars that we gave you this summer and
he says mom we are adults we don't need
to tell you what we're doing what we're
doing with our moment that's right you
don't and then you don't get my money
yeah people will not take my advice and
will not be accountable for the
behaviors will not get money okay so
he's banging here okay he's being an
arrogant entitled person yeah yeah okay
well that that supports my feeling it's
not grace grace is give is being kind to
someone and lifting them up when they're
hurting
it's not support it's not giving a drunk
a drink right when you encourage
someone's crazy or you encourage
someone's irresponsibility by financing
it that's not grace that's called
enabling it's a psychological disorder